[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL GRAY: In April of
1968, Martin Luther King
was assassinated.
The small number of
African-American students
created a Black
Student Union at MIT.
SHIRLEY ANN JACKSON:
The Black Student Union
presented a list of demands
to the administration,
except we actually
called them proposals.
JAMES M. TURNER:
We felt that MIT
could be significantly enhanced
by having more minority
students here.
SYLVESTER JAMES GATES, JR.:
Many people questioned our right
to be here at MIT.
Many people questioned
our abilities
to succeed at the
academic endeavor.
There were people who
questioned whether
African-American students
had the capacity to innovate
in intellectual fields.
PAUL GRAY: We created
a summer program called
Project Interphase,
which still operates
and was staffed largely by
African-American graduate
students.
JAMES M. TURNER: We
wanted to do what
we could to ease the
transition into MIT.
SYLVESTER JAMES
GATES, JR.: I was
in the first Project Interphase,
which took place in 1969.
JAMES M. TURNER:
Part of the thing
was to bring them
up to the campus
the summer before they would
start so they could learn
the campus, so they
could meet each other,
and so they would
come here and not feel
like they were on an island.
SYLVESTER JAMES
GATES, JR.: I had
to learn how to study
and manage my time.
All of that happened during
Project Interphase for me.
PAUL GRAY: We taught
get-up-to-speed subjects
in physics and math.
There was a humanities program,
and there was an athletics
and social program.
REGINALD VAN LEE: You
weren't just being
taught by MIT professors.
You were being taught by other
minority students, many of whom
had gone through
Interphase that were peers,
but were role models
for you as well.
SYLVESTER JAMES
GATES, JR.: A couple
of our students in Project
Interphase who had not
had calculus in high school
came to Project Interphase
and learned calculus.
And they placed out
of 1801 and 1802.
REGINALD VAN LEE: And
with that launch pad,
it made it easier to
take a risk, to step out,
to have confidence, to be
courageous, all those things
that got me through MIT and
has gotten me through my life
since.
JAMES M. TURNER: So
Interphase was this experiment
that kind of said, you know,
yeah, these people can do this.
REGINALD VAN LEE:
The best way to solve
a problem is to bring multiple
perspectives to that problem.
And the best way to solve
the problems of the world
is to make sure that all the
people that touch that problem
are taken into account as
you drive to the solution.
SHIRLEY ANN JACKSON: Paul
created an amazing foundation.
And so there wouldn't
be a real presence
if it weren't for what
went on during that period.
PAUL GRAY: Maybe the
most important thing
I did around here.
REGINALD VAN LEE: I owe a large
portion of my success at MIT,
and I would even say
since MIT, to Interphase.
SYLVESTER JAMES GATES,
JR.: Project Interphase
was the singular most
important academic experience
I ever had in my life.
REGINALD VAN LEE: One could
hope that you wouldn't
need an Interphase anymore
because all the disparities are
gone, and we're
all very diverse,
and all the stakeholders
are engaged.
But that's not the case.
And so I think that the work
of Interphase is so important,
changing the lives of
students like myself,
contributing to the success
of MIT and the impact
and footprint that it's
making on society at large.
So we'll go 45 more years until
we don't need to exist anymore.
[MUSIC PLAYING]